what's going on guys this is rob and i
have a theory
sylvie
created the illuminati not intentionally
but she created them okay let's uh
just explain this a little bit we're
gonna have to invoke a little bit of
comic book knowledge granted almost
cinematic universe plays by its own
rules but they do borrow from marvel
comics so
to make this simple let's say there's
timeline a and timeline b timeline a is
everything that's happened in the
history of the marvel cinematic universe
every origin story when odin opened up
with thor the dark world and told us
like the very early days of things the
creation of the infinity stones
everything you've ever seen in the
marvel cinematic universe
chronologically leading up to the events
of the end of loki that's timeline a now
our perception
switched from timeline a to timeline b
when sylvie killed he who remains here's
a reason why so as you guys know from
our different discussions and really
just in general regarding the events of
loki that when sylvie killed he who
remains the whole role that he who
remains had was to basically eliminate
universes that would lead to the
creation of kane the conqueror so the
multiverse existed it's just that the
only universes that did exist were
universes that would lead to the
creation of he who remains as opposed to
king the conqueror so if tony stark and
pepper potts are walking through the
park and a bird craps in tony stark's
eye and that leads to the formation of
kane the conqueror then the tva would
step in and they would prune that
universe probably kill a bird good job
bird you killed a whole universe but
that's basically the role the tda played
loki was part of it and silvie was kind
of a part of it but not necessarily but
our perception switching to timeline b
the question has to be asked how did it
change right silvie killed he who
remains she pushed loki through a portal
back to the tva headquarters but when
loki got there no one knew who he was
he'd been working all this time with
owen wilson but always wilson had no
idea who loki was no one did and instead
of there being statues of the time
keepers there were statues of king the
conqueror now remember the tva exists
outside of time so it's not as though
loki was pushed to some alternate
universe version of the tva there's only
one time variance authority in the
entirety of the multiverse so the only
way to adequately answer this question
is to say that when he who remains died
and the multiverse was spiraling out of
control essentially all these different
alternate universes that would
eventually give birth to kane the
conqueror all came into existence
perhaps this multiversal war started
again we're not entirely sure what we do
know is that seemingly one of those
kings went back to the very beginning of
the timeline or whenever the original
multiversal war happened ensured that
they won and they're the ones who formed
the time variance authority now exactly
what role the time variance authority
played in this timeline b we're not
entirely sure the only thing that we
really get that that gives us any kind
of preview or insight into it is when
loki ends up back at the tva and
everybody's under the control of kane
the conqueror one for them it's always
been that way there's never any
indication they have any idea of who
immortus is as far as they're concerned
they've always worked for kang and the
tva has always been controlled by king
the other thing that goes on is they're
saying let the multiverse grow right let
all these alternate realities come into
existence do not stop them that's what
he wants that's what he wants to have
happen and so if that's the case then
when it comes to marvel comics in
general one of the things that's been
solidified over and over and over again
specifically during jonathan hickman's
avengers new avengers jonathan hickman's
avengers new year's oh god one of the
things that's just been hit at over and
over again when it comes to this is that
basically the multiverse exists in a
form of balance there's a yen for every
yang that's been said time and time
again baron mordo said it in the doctor
strange films that seemingly it exists
whenever the tba is talking that this
kind of balance always has to be
maintained now traditionally this is a
role that would be maintained for the
living tribunal the living tribunal
would exist to make sure there's always
a multiversal balance but what do we
know about the living tribunal well we
don't really know much outside of the
fact that his head was basically in the
graveyard of places that have been
pruned by the time variance authority we
don't know if it was really a statue or
if like the the living tribunal had been
destroyed or whatever the case is but
like a statue of his head was in that
graveyard of places where things had
been pruned and that was basically it
but as far as we're aware the living
tribunal does not exist in the marvel
cinematic universe now this is where the
theory comes into play or at least the
comic book knowledge of the theory comes
into play so during jonathan hickman's
avengers and new avengers when the
multiverse was collapsing and everything
was coming to an end on one side he had
the illuminati so reed richards black
panther namor the submariner all those
guys who are basically working together
to try to find a way to end the
multiversal incursions on the other side
you had the white lords of wild space
right the beyonders the ones who had
kind of caused it but not really then
you had doctor doom and the molecule man
as the actual cause of the multiversal
incursions but then you had the black
priests now we've talked about the black
priests before here on geek culture
explain and they are a phenomenal
concept but basically we didn't know
where the black priest came from in
jonathan hickman's avengers new avengers
all we knew is that they were just
suddenly there right that when the
illuminati were using the bridge of reed
richards to look into alternate
realities that they saw these black
priests were showing up to entire
universes and destroying them right
wiping them all out in their entirety
technically they were destroying the
earth because if you destroy the earth
and there is no point where the earth
can make contact and the universe came
in this dreads great huge thing the
whole point is that the the black
priests are basically destroying earth
to prevent the multiversal collapse what
we ended up learning here is that if the
multiverse was a living organism which
is to say a human being that could get
up and walk around the black priests
were the antibodies that's all they were
it was the the multiverse's own defense
system trying to ensure its survival to
make sure that it wouldn't die out with
the multiversal collapse eventually dr
strange took over the black priest now
i'm not saying the illuminati are the
black priests what i'm saying here is
that when sylvie went and killed he who
remains she changed not simply just the
tva but the entirety of the multiversal
time stream the whole nine yards she
basically reset the multiverse right
except this time it was not he who
remains that won the multiversal war it
was kang who won the multiverse award
but if the purpose behind the tva was to
guard the sacred timeline they were able
to maintain some kind of a balance and
seemingly the multiverse existed in
harmony nobody really had any complaints
outside of sylvie but the thing about
this is that with all of that gone the
multiverse just running amok any
possibility that can't exist does exist
which means somebody has to maintain
order and so whether it was a result of
circumstance or some meditextual concept
the illuminati was essentially formed as
a result of the death of he who remains
and the absence of the tva as we
traditionally know them now the reason
why i say this is one of those
meditextual things is because you could
literally argue and they do this in
comics all the time you could argue it
was just kind of the way the cards felt
right it was the universe sort of
organizing things in such a way to where
a group would rise that would serve the
purpose of trying to safeguard the
multiverse here's the real kicker about
this question you have to ask is do the
illuminati know about kane the conqueror
do they know any of the events that
happened in loki and my answer to that
question would be no the illuminati
would have no idea the only person who
knows what's going on with the timeline
as a result of the death of he who
remains and the idea of king and all
that kind of stuff is loki loki's the
only one who knows the way that things
were originally supposed to be he's the
only one who knows right because
seemingly he's the only one who
witnessed the death of a mortise when he
went back to the tva nobody knew him
right owen wilson none of those guys
it's not like he went back to the tva
and he was like oh and wilson man
everything's popping off right it's just
it's the end times you know it's just
you know he remains as dead still he
killed him and now everything's changed
and no one's like okay to the bat cave
loki and then they went to go solve the
problem that's not what happened right
they didn't know him so as far as owen
wilson and then were concerned it had
always been that way and i would say
with the illuminati it's going to be the
exact same thing that as far as they're
concerned the multiverse had always been
like this because there's nothing to
indicate that it hadn't they weren't
aware of how things were before
everything changed but that's the idea
behind this theory right that's my
thought here that silvi inadvertently
created the illuminati the illuminati
are really in effect the multiverse
trying to fix itself the multiverse
trying to correct things now it could be
that i'm entirely wrong here honestly i
don't really care but the cool thing is
that i love this possibility i love this
idea that the illuminati are basically
the result of just fate if that's what
you want to call it right that in this
new timeline things just aren't right
and the multiverse is trying to set
itself back to where things are supposed
to be and by virtue of fate or the hand
of god whatever you want to call it it's
just kind of rearranging the pieces in
such a way to where an alternative to
the tva emerges right that there's
always a kind of similarity that there's
always some kind of yen to a yang or
something along those lines so let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments section i'm curious what your
ideas are on this and uh thank you all
for watching and i'll catch you all
later
peace